hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the us chess championship we
have a very nice game between fabiano
corona and john burke both of them i had
a pretty pretty good start fabi uh
started out with two draws but uh burke
started with a win against dario
schwerch and also a draw against
slenderman so i will see what happens in
this one and for those of you who do not
know fabi dropped out of the 2800 club
he's currently at
27.99
so he only needs to gain one rating
point in this classical tournament to be
back into the 2800 club otherwise uh
magnus will be residing there alone for
well until someone someone joins him uh
so that being said uh let's check out
the game uh fabi with the white pieces
opens with e4 and also if you guys are
interested uh john burke is the youngest
player ever to achieve the rating of
2600.
so burke replies with e5 that's not an f
pawn we have knight to f3 knight to c6
and now bishop to b5 fabi goes for the
rue lopez
a6 morpheus defense bishop to a4 and
knight to f6 we have d3
the anderson variation those of you who
have been watching the the morphy saga
know why it's the anderson variation uh
we have b5 chasing back the bishop
bishop to b3 and bishop to c5 so this is
very standard stuff we have c3 uh
preparing some future strikes in the
center and also this bishop will be
retreated to c2 as the knight usually
attacks it via the a5 square so d6 and
now bishop to g5 pinning the knight with
h6 chasing back the bishop and bishop to
h4 and now
there are a couple of options you could
go for here the position uh is a known
one you could castle you could further
harass the bishop with the g5 or you
could play what mr burke played here and
that is bishop to e7 it's a known move
in the royal opus has many uh purposes
but
in this particular position it is a new
one so uh it's a as of nine that we have
a completely new game so one of the uh
useful uh ideas behind bishop to a7 is
that when the a file opens up black's
rook will not be hanging so you don't
have to really hurry up with the
development of the
uh of the light square bishop but you'll
see what i mean by this we have castles
uh and now knight to a5 chasing back the
bishop the bishop to c2 and now g5 so
expanding on the king side and queen
side both bishop to g3 and now knight to
h5 with the idea of just capturing this
bishop but also uh in some lines maybe
the knight can come to f4 it's going to
be a very powerful piece if black wants
to eliminate it maybe we can open up the
g file to be used for attacking purposes
we have a4 now a4 is even nicer as the
knight on a5 is undefended so captures
would allow us to have a
more than one attack so knight captures
on g3 attacking the rook of course fabio
recaptures with the h pawn and knight
back to c6 and now fabi captures on b5 a
captures a captures and now as the
bishop is on a7 our rook and a8 is not
hanging so there you have it we have
night day 3 fabi continues developing
with tempo the b5 pawn is under attack
and now black has to decide
how to react to this do you
just advance the pawn to b4 because
that's often a very good move
or do you go bishop to a6 and defend the
pawn like mr burke did in this game so
here fabi plays bishop to b3 the bishop
will be incredibly useful on this
diagonal and now knight to e7 black
wants to start
advancing the the pawns the c5 sofa be
beats him to it he plays d4 uh and now e
captures on d4 and now although you want
to capture with the c pawn and improve
your center then you just invite black
to play c5 and then black um pretty much
sold all of his problems he has a very
nice bishop pair here uh that's a weird
arrow he has a very nice bishop pair
here and he's gonna have a very
enjoyable game so fabi captures with the
knight uh and this comes now with the
tempo as the b5 pawn is again hanging so
before now
uh opening up an attack on the knight
but also on the rook on f1 so knight to
c4 the only move and now uh you have to
do something because your bishop on a6
is hanging so bishop captures on c4
bishop captures and only now uh burke
castles and now fabi says all right uh i
could capture here this will uh double
my b pawns but i will be up upon so pawn
captures on b4
and now what do you play here uh well
you could consider something like bishop
to b6 just offering a rook trade you are
down upon but it's a double b pawn and
it's not even a pass pawn so you could
capture on d4
you could do a lot of things but black
decides to play d5
offers another pawn for for some
activity and okay fabi accepts it we
have e captures on d5 uh not bishop
captures because you really don't want
to give up your your light square bishop
so pawn captures on d5 and now queen to
d6 but now
there is a problem in this position and
uh even though it seems like black
activated for for the price of a few
pawns uh the position is winning for
fabi uh so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this move while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on going for this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's knight
to e6
no it's not that's joke it's of course
knight to b5 attacking the queen and the
bishop and our rook and knight are now
attacking the bishop twice so the queen
will capture on b4 now attacking the
bishop here on c4 and black was probably
hoping that we might see a draw here
like rook captures and then queen
captures here we we just trade
everything but here fabi just played b3
and this b3 is the important move you
had to see after you decided to play
knight to b5 because now what does black
play the bishop is hanging and you have
to do something the problem is if you
play something like bishop to b6
we simply trade rook captures rook
captures and play queen to f3 and now we
will have incredible pressure here look
at this bishop and queen once we push
this pawn then even the rook might be
hanging on a8 so after something like
rook to f8 getting rid of both threats
now queen f6 going after the h6 pawn and
there's really no good way to defend if
king h7 we just play d6 and that's it
the entire position just falls apart the
knight is attacked the f7 pawn is
attacked if if bishop captures then we
can simply go queen g6 if the knight
moves uh so there really isn't all that
much uh now the queen is no longer
guarding the knight because the pawn is
here the queen can't capture because the
knight guards the pawn so we might see
something like knight to g6 but then
even d captures on c7 we have a
beautiful pass pawn on c7 that's not the
only winning move most of them are
winning but just to give you an idea so
uh just moving the bishop not all that
great so here
we have queen to c5 adding a defender
here but now again queen to f3 and now
what do you play here uh well king to g7
of course he wants to prevent queen to
f6 going after the h6 pawn but now fabi
has rook to a6 now again we're
threatening to bring the queen over to
f6 uh and again bishop to b6 uh
just fails to the same idea captures
captures and then we play d6 and that's
it the rook is hanging the knight is
hanging the f7 is hanging so everything
is just hanging here so after rook to a6
black plays f6 yes this does prevent the
queen from reaching f6 as the rook now
defends it but this is not one of those
positions where it's okay to play f6 and
now fabi uh goes for the absolute
simplest uh idea and that is rook f2a1
triples up here or rather has now a
triple attack on the a7 bishop uh we
defended knight the c8 and now fabi just
plays the uh i believe the most
beautiful move of the game and that is
king to h2 that's it he was in this
position on move 29 that john burke
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
and it's a it's a it's a remarkable
position because there is not a single
piece that black can move uh you can't
move the bishop the rook hangs you can't
move the rook we're just going to win
the bishop you can't move the knight
because the knight defends the bishop
you can't move the queen the queen
defends the bishop uh the rook is stuck
here guarding this f6 pawn if the rook
moves we're going to capture it so there
is no move black can make here other
than some sort of a silly pawn push and
even if you try to waste the move with
some like rook to f7 to still keep an
eye on this pawn d6 once again wins the
game now this rook is hanging this rook
is hanging everything is hanging and if
you just repeat rook to f8 we don't even
have to capture here we can even play d7
dislodge the knight we can just you know
play anything and it's still completely
winning
so it's a a position that really went
wrong for black uh he had uh
he had a he had a good position for the
most of the game but then at some point
after he decided to well uh probably to
give up this this pawn here or maybe you
could have done something better you
know even sooner uh it's a it's an
active move but uh playing an active
move against fabi that's not really uh
justified it's just not gonna work
because like i said fabi is currently
almost a 2800 player 27
99.8 so that's really really close and
probably he will reach his uh goal of uh
uh again uh joining the 2800 member club
uh after this tournament but we'll see
it's a strong opposition you know it
just because fabi's the highest rated
player here doesn't mean that he's going
to win and uh if you check out the
previous uh championships uh it's never
that simple uh but yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and that
you've learned a little bit more about
the rue lopez and how wild it really is
i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to ita i hope you have a great
day and many many more to come and of
course filled with chess and the joy
and i would like to thank idol gurmuk
michael kennedy tom daryl and robert
kiefer for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the us chess
championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day